congratulations to Arizona they have
proven everyone wrong along the way they
swept two division winners they got past
the fighting fills how they do it Pedro
well they did it with pitching defense
and playing actually something that we
didn't see in the first two games which
was the the the Diamondbacks chaos kind
of game that they played and we saw it
in full display the last two games and
that's what they needed to do if they
wanted to beat the mighty offense at the
Philadelphia f and they said it before
game five Jimmy they called it a
must-win they knew winning two at the
bank would be a tall task and Christian
Walker said we know what you you're
saying about us we know you don't think
we're supposed to be here we love it we
use it as fuel that's been their uh
rally and cry all season long you know
uh you guys didn't expect this but
secretly inside this Clubhouse of course
you did you C it but secretly inside
this Clubhouse we knew the type of team
that we had and they finally showed up
to play their style of baseball now
getting on base uh press ing the other
team but more than anything something
they've done all postseason long and
that's come up clutch Big Two Out hits
not letting a rally die with a runner
get the scoring position kept pushing
congratulations to the Diamond Backs
they deserved it they played better and
the pitching oh my goodness oh my
goodness I mean you the pressure and the
willingness to take chances on the bases
and set up the runs Jimmy said it the
two out hits the speed that's their game
critic they won at their game they
finally did it you know aggressive
behavior like they had talked about we
didn't see it the first part of the
season but that's what they had did for
162 games now they're in the postseason
not only did they get hits they stole
four bases they did a hit and run or a
run and hit however it was put some
action on them and put the ball in play
sack bunts and Sack flies things that we
thought are a lost art in this game all
came into play tonight you love that G
oh I love it because that's we forget
about it for the rest of the season but
when you need to win a game you go ahead
and execute it even the Phillies were
trying to sack bunt tonight when the
game is on the line the fundamentals
have to come through and they showed it
tonight yeah they were trying to squeeze
out runs can we love on Corbin Carrol
for a second second I have it written
down second youngest player in MLB
history with three hits and two steals
in a playoff game only Tai Cobb was
younger he affects the game in so many
ways he does and it was critical for him
to have the game that he had tonight we
saw what it was like um in the first
what six games you know them having to
move him around but when he's doing his
job he's getting on basees causing Havoc
even if he's not stealing the threat of
it it keeps the defense on there toes
but tonight everything worked for him
big hit after big hit getting on base
when they when he goes they go he
carries that attitude not he's he's the
energy yes I like what um Cel Marte
brings to it but when this guy is
on everybody else just picks up the
slice like here we go guys we're on a
train let's get going Pedro you see the
pitcher when he's on first base he is
looking over his shoulder the entire
time well and and and it wasn't just
Carol doing that right but everybody
that got on base was forcing the issue
including Walker that last inning stole
the bag they were doing exactly what the
Diamondbacks have been preaching they
they pitched they play defense and they
caused chaos in in around around the
field and that's what they did they did
it to Perfection and kudos suori lulo
for doing the things that he was doing
too with his team sometimes we got
desperate out here like the first game
with with fad I I thought I thought he
was rushing into taking him out but
today he did perfectly when I thought he
was going to pull him a little bit
earlier I thought he was going to pull
him when he got in trouble a little bit
and he gave up the two runs I thought he
was going to pull him and then he left
him in there finished the inning and
started the inning fresh with another
pitcher how does anyone hit gle's
breaking ball I mean we love on the
starters and rightfully so we have one
of the best to ever do it right here on
this desk but there are bullpens Across
America whose names you don't know they
are your Lifeline in October we're
watching the game back there with all
the Turner staff back there like how did
how does he make the ball do
that yeah just like that I'm like that's
why he's a pitcher that's why he's one
of the best I mean everything looks like
a fast ball out of the hand and it's
just moving out moving out even if
you're saying not swing they're doing it
all there and he's deceptive and they
got swinging Miss after swinging better
stuff than the the closer filthy look my
breaking ball by the way it's like this
like it looked just like that it's
unable congratulations to Arizona the NL
pennet belongs to the Diamond Back game
seven of the NLCS we got you John krook
throwing up the first pitch you had to
get the overalls Jimmy of course John
like all Phillies fans
do and it was bedum at the bank deal
city as they call it it was so good
Arizona struck first with a Christian
Walker RBI and then in the bottom of the
second nobody out Alec bom first pitch
fast ball over the wall left center
field solo shot the very first pitch he
saw what's it called a
ding
yes please to even the score so Alec bum
walked in the fourth and Bryson St said
come on home and bottom of the fourth
one out a lineer to the Gap and left
center field scoring his bone from first
this was interesting because the middle
of the order showing up for Philly we
talked so much about not letting the big
guys beat you and it was them first look
at price and the crowd look at the
decibal 107 what's considered like I
don't know actually just thinking that I
should Google it di back to do the
little things well it helps when you
have the Rookie of the Year showing out
Corbin Carroll what a game a grounder to
Center RBI single Emanuel Rivera scores
like the Sinker Gabriel Moreno liner to
right field remember he was moved to the
third spot in the order of this series
he had never hit there before before the
championship H the MVP too gets caught
trying to go to second to end the inning
but the lead is taken the damage is done
Philly's Bullpen fully loaded listen to
this Jose Alvarado with a 0.0 ER in the
postseason on the mound carbin carols is
nine more I mean selfless really sack
fly sack fly you know just doing the
things that you need to do put the ball
in playoff for one of the toughest
lefties in the game and now you get an
insurance run right there that put you
up too Alvarado's first run allowed in
the postseason this dude this is my man
what can you say about kin gingle he was
everything you needed him to be and that
was really the only pitch that was right
there he kind of not that he's hungry he
threw it for a good strike that's the
only pitch that wasn't absolutely filthy
hey was completely dominant came in five
outs nobody had an answer he is and it's
hard to explain that sometimes those
setup men uh are probably better than
the closers strike away here
or last call for the Phillies Paul
sewald to Jake cave a pop up in game
seven is in the books it's in the glove
the baseball of the Rookie of the Year
Corbin Carol Pomo taking a moment for
himself and Arizona doubles up the
Phillies in game seven of the National
League Championship Series
congratulations to Arizona heading to
their first World Series since 2001 they
will meet up with the Rangers in
Arlington and what a ride it has been
for Philadelphia they got through
Milwaukee they got through Atlanta think
about that seems like a month ago
doesn't it one of the best lineups in
all the game and they had opportunities
first and second we always go back to
that seventh inning Trey and bright it
felt like that was the moment in time if
it was going to happen and and you're
100% correct I think all of us to
ourselves at least maybe I'm speaking
for myself I don't want to project I'm
like this is it you know not that it
can't happen but this if something
special is going to happen you have the
guys up that you want up we saw with
Bryce last year hitting the Home Run
sending the uh Phillies to the World
Series I'm like is it going to happen
two years in a row and he got a pitch to
hit I mean it was a fast ball middle
away and he just caught the bottom of
the ball but look you had the guys up
that you
wanted got to give credit when credits
due their Bullpen was lights out all
night may have gotten away with a
pitched to Bryce but when things are
going to happen for you we all know
sometimes it's just Destiny you can do
everything wrong and it works out right
throwing a fast ball to Bryce right
there in the situation and getting away
with it it almost seems like it was it
was just meant to be I for a second I
was shaking in my boots and I said to
you guys what I said some people aren't
built for October not people came out go
you if you're not a baseball fan this is
the time you watch they make that
pitching change like all right all the
action all the time you get 96 down the
middle of the plate and Bryce popped
eyes it what do you throw into Trey
Turner and Bryce Harper in that moment
what are you trying to do well I guess
uh I I needed to throw the same fast B
he just thre because he got him out you
start messing around with the breaking
ball there it might hit it 450 fet but
uh you just have to give him a lot of
credit for uh being so God see and and
and you know challenging uh uh both of
those guys and making pitches also but
you know what what probably had Harper a
little bit off that fast but was that
the sharp breaking ball he was throwing
it was like 87 dropping straight down
12-6 and and perfectly located I also
have to give a lot of credit to Gabriel
Moreno framing blocking allowing those
guys to actually bounce those balls and
and feel like they're
they're not going to let one go back
behind the the back stop I I I thought
Moreno did a great job could have easily
be be the MVP uh right right along with
catel Marte but um overall Arizona just
doing it I mean in all angles it did not
end the Phillies way but there's a lot
to be proud of for that Philadelphia
Philly Squad and Matt Wier had a chance
to talk with their Skipper Rob Thompson
not long
ago rob a 2 lead a 3-2 lead lead how did
this get away well we you know the
Diamondbacks played well and they
pitched well and they neutralized some
of our guys we had we had some
opportunities tonight but uh you know it
didn't come through and that's that's
baseball you got to tip your cap to them
um you know they they played their game
when they came back here and to come in
this building and beat us in this
atmosphere twice um that's it's an
accomplishment and so you tip your cap
there were big expectations here
obviously can you take any consolation
from reaching this round from the wild
card spot well you know I I think it's
difficult to get to this round backto
back years it really is you got to have
a good club and you got to have some
breaks along the way and you got to play
well um so I you know I'm proud of our
club for the way they played in the way
they they battled all year long um we're
very disappointed but um but they they
have nothing to be ashamed of Rob
thanks absolutely nothing I was just
looking at the free agents for Phil
Philadelphia Nola Lorenzen Kimbrell
Hoskins this is going to be largely the
same team next year chtis it's balanced
it's got experience I think that's going
to be the biggest thing you have a team
like Tom said that's been their backtack
years they've learned from it they're
hungry they're ready to get back to it
you build on that experience plus you
bring in a piece or two CU you know
they're going to do something this
offseason whether it's a trade or a free
AG J Rous is going to do more than one
he's already on the phone probably
already phone bring that piece in that
fits that culture that blue collar
mentality that rough Philadelphia
mindset that fits in and they're back at
it again I was just thinking looking at
the Arizona Diamondback celebrating it
is such a beautiful grind right pitchers
and catchers Pedro they report in
February we're in late October now and
these teams aren't done it is a
beautiful grind over 162 and it is to be
celebrated for all these teams yes and I
I I actually have to use one word to
describe the Diamond Backs is grid and
character that's two yeah but but I'm
just saying you can you can choose
whichever one you want to Define that to
Define this team because both of them
come together you don't have grit
without character and you don't have
character without grit and this team is
struggle they went to the lows of lows
and the highs of highs and you're seeing
it right now but they they somehow
remain playing the same game stuck to
the plan that they had and and even when
we were upset here seeing how they use
their pictures and go back to the buen
they continue to execute the plan that
they had the entire season they did not
run into Panic they they got their butts
kick early in the season they didn't pay
attention to that and they just kept
rolling and rolling and playing the
Diamond Backs game that they know how to
play and here they are in the postseason
congratulations
you can't find chemistry on baseball
reference can you we talk all the time
about Ops and average it takes culture
and to lell built it in Arizona and
perhaps they are not that there's a guy
popping bottles laurenn the burn you
know gosh put the goggles over your eyes
nope got to earn it yeah and
congratulations back after this